Margot Robbie Emma Mackey Margo Mackey
Emma Robbie you wouldn't be the first
person to get these two actors mixed up
and even Barbie had something to say
about their resemblance before the line
got cut some celebrities just really
really look alike
I'm seeing double here four krusties
Isla Fisher once put Amy Adams's face on
her own Christmas cards to see if
anybody would notice Bryce Dallas Howard
and Jessica Chastain apparently spend
inordinate amounts of time insisting
that they're not the same person and if
you've ever watched Netflix's original
series sex education you'll know that
star Emma Mackey who plays Maeve Bears a
striking resemblance to Barbie star and
Academy Award nominee Margot Robbie in
fact it was the resemblance that led to
Mackie appearing in the Barbie movie and
an early version of the film even
acknowledged their similar looks
according to Robbie this moment had to
be cut from the final product speaking
to BuzzFeed during one of their patented
puppy interviews Robbie said she plays
one of the Barbies in the movie pretty
much because Greta Gerwig and I thought
it would be funny Gerwig and Robbie
actually came up with a joke about the
pair of similar appearances but when all
was said and done it didn't land the way
they thought it would we were going to
do this whole joke about us looking
similar and once we got all dressed up
as our Barbies we were kind of like we
don't actually look that similar as it
turned out the two actors don't look all
that similar when one is rocking blonde
hair and the other's a brunette so we
didn't put that joke in the movie but
when people come up to me and say I
loved you in sex education I just say
thank you Maeve Wiley mackie's character
on sex education changes up her hair
color a lot throughout the show and it's
worth acknowledging that as a blonde she
definitely resembles Robbie the joke
clearly didn't land on the Barbie set
due to mackie's Natural Hue so it's
probably for the best that they didn't
bother forcing it nevertheless Mackie is
a key part of the final product as
physicist Barbie one of the residents of
Barbie land with whom Robbie's
stereotypical Barbie spends time
throughout the film in fact Margot
Robbie first met Emma Mackey around the
time they were both cast and Barbie so
maybe it's not surprising that only
after the fact did they decide they
didn't resemble one another enough to
joke about it Robbie briefly detailed
what it was like working with Mackie
during a filmed interview for Sirius
xm's the Jess Cagle show while
discussing a prank of sorts Ryan Gosling
played on the rest of the cast during
filming of the movie girls night scene
Robbie recounted feeling nostalgic about
childhood sleepovers while brushing her
teeth in a mirror alongside mackie's
physicist Barbie and we like shared a
bed and I was like and we only met like
two weeks ago like this I love it it's
like we bonded so quickly and I think
sleepover had a lot to do with it
according to Robbie's BuzzFeed interview
she and Greta Gerwig offered Mackie a
part in Barbie at least in part based on
her famous resemblance to Robbie even
though that didn't end up informing
their character's relationship in the
film it seems the two got along well on
set all the same allowing Mackie to
remain a part of its ensemble cast
[Music]